diesen sommer wurde der gaza streifen
vom dritten krieg innerhalb von sechs
jahren zerrissen
seit rund zwei wochen schweigen nun die
waffen dennoch stellt sich natürlich die
frage wie geht es weiter im gazastreifen
ist ein frieden in dieser region
überhaupt noch möglich und welche rolle
können internationale diplomatie und
insbesondere auch die schweiz im
internationalen krisen generell spielen
diese fragen sind heute thema der
sternstunde philosophie herzlich
willkommen
mein gast heute ist der krähenbühl
er ist seit diesem jahr generalkommissar
der uno agentur für palästina
flüchtlinge
tja krähenbühl haben sie diesen tweet
gesehen
stehen hatte ich nicht gesehen kann ich
nicht sehe ich zum ersten mal das war
ein tritt der innerhalb kürzester zeit
über 100.000 menschen erreicht hat er
wurde abgesetzt einem sinne einer anti
israelischen propaganda man sieht
darüber steht die israelische armee malt
kriegswunden und er wollte darauf
aufmerksam machen dass in diesen krieg
viele dinge geschehen die eben
propagandistisch sind kurze zeit darauf
hat man aber herausgefunden dass diese
bilder alle gefälscht sind respektive
zusammengesetzt aus irgendwelchen
seminaren über das schminken von
kriegswunden propaganda also hüben und
drüben kann man sich in diesen krieg
überhaupt noch irgendwie neutral
informieren
also erstmal gehört propaganda als jeden
krieg ich bin jetzt seit 25 jahren
hinkriegen im einsatz
es existiert überall die polarisierung
die es in solchen umwelten natürlich
gibt es extrem stark auch gerade jetzt
in dieser gegend in diesem konflikt
zwischen israel und palästinensern
und ich glaube das ist einfach ein teil
des umfeld ist in dem ich arbeite seit
jahren und auch jetzt wieder in dieser
rolle
das heißt neutralität ist natürlich eine
art und weise aufzutreten in diesem
fleckchen ich bin nicht neutral geboren
natürlich habe ich wie jeder emotionen
habe ich gewisse instinkte habe ich auch
meine persönlichen werte und die sind
natürlich auch teil der personen der
jetzt als generalkommissar der der uno
dort auftritt aber was besonders
schwierig ist in einem konflikt ist die
wahrnehmung durch andere meiner
neutralität ich versuche natürlich
neutral aufzutreten
ich versuche die verschiedenen
perspektiven zu verstehen aber wie das
dann wahrgenommen wird es wenn dann noch
mal eine andere frage und darin besteht
eine sehr große herausforderung
sie haben jetzt insbesondere auch über
ihre rolle und die neutralität
gesprochen
mir war aber auch ein anliegen darüber
zu sprechen wie informieren sich einen
nicht die menschen in diesem konflikt
die ja dann eben auch entsprechend
informationen bräuchten um sich zu
wehren oder für eine seite auch partei
zu ergreifen
also lasst mich immer beeindruckt ist in
einer solchen lage ist ob jemand noch
fähig ist eine andere perspektive als
seine eigene mit einzubeziehen
ich finde immer in konfliktgebieten
steht der mut nicht darin dass man seine
eigene überzeugung weiterhin vertritt
und unbedingt insistiert dass man recht
hat sondern dass man auch in solchen
schwierigen situationen versucht zu
verstehen wie ist auf der anderen seite
aussieht und das ist natürlich eine
große aus forderung werden ich habe mich
oft gefragt wäre wäre ich jetzt wenn ich
ein israeli wäre oder wenn ich ein
palästinenser wäre wäre ich jetzt in
gaza geboren oder in tel aviv die würde
ich das selber betracht natürlich würde
jeder hoffen ich wäre ein kritischer
journalist oder ein
menschenrechtsaktivist aber die tatsache
ist das weiß man nicht ich bin jetzt
nicht in tel aviv geboren ich bin nicht
in gaza geboren ich bin in genf geboren
und das beeinflusst natürlich auch die
art und weise wie ich die lage war nehme
aber ich finde sehr wichtig im austausch
zu bleiben mut in solchen situationen
heißt man geht dem anderen ein stück
entgegen und versucht die perspektive zu
verstehen und nicht einfach recht haben
zu wollen
das klingt natürlich alles sehr schön in
diesem speziellen konflikt ist es ja
auch wahrscheinlich der fall dass die
fronten so dermaßen verhärtet sind wir
der konflikt ja schon sehr lang gedauert
er dauert jetzt baut schon 100 jahre und
er beginnt mit unermesslichen unrecht
auf beiden seiten
was wenn wir in der geschichte
zurückblicken kurz nach dem holocaust
haben sehr sehr viele juden zuflucht
gesucht
im heutigen land israel und das ist auch
geschehen wir sehen hier ein bild mit
juden auf einem schiff weil die juden
nirgendwo einlass gefunden haben das ist
ein bild von 1948 das schiff steht vor
haifa und diese juden mussten irgendwo
hin können und das war der ort den sie
dann zugesprochen erhalten haben
auf der anderen seite war dieses land
bereits bewohnt die palästinenser waren
da und im gleichen jahr 1948 auch hier
ein bild sind 700.000 palästinenser
bereits auf der flucht sie werden
vertrieben sie können nicht mehr da
bleiben wo sie gewohnt haben wenn wir
uns das vor augen führen kann man dann
nicht irgendwann einfach sagen es ist
gar nicht mehr möglich vor dem
hintergrund einer solchen historischen
unrechts
noch frieden zu erwarten denn es ist
sehr notwendig sich gerade dafür
einzusetzen weil es gerade wenn die lage
so schwierig ist dass man sich engagiert
man engagiert sich ja nicht persönlich
wenn die lage einfach ist im leben
es ist gerade weil die lage so
festgefahren ist und ist eben bei so
vielen menschen dieses gefühl des
unrechtes aber natürlich auch der
überlebenskraft die aus ihnen kommt
gerade aus dem zweiten weltkrieg kann
man ja durchaus nachvollziehen
insbesondere als europäer müssen wir uns
daran erinnern weshalb ist überhaupt
dazu kam natürlich nach dem holocaust
und diese suche der juden nach einem
land wo sie in sicherheit sein würden
das kann jeder nachvollziehen das kann
ich heute nachvollziehen
und das muss man verstehen das ist
natürlich gleichzeitig klar dass
sicherheit nicht auf kosten der würde
und rechte einer anderen gemeinschaft
oder bevölkerungsgruppe gebaut werden
kann jedenfalls nicht langfristig und
deswegen ist dieses zusammenleben dieses
nebeneinander leben sehr wichtig ich
traf vor kurzem jemanden in gaza das ist
ein unternehmer und er sagte mir dass
folgende er sagte mir ich bin ein guter
mensch aber meine kinder sind nicht so
gut wie und wie ich und das musste ich
erst mal verstehen und ich habe immer
gesagt und dann sagte er mir ich habe
mein leben lang als palästinenser in
israelischen fabriken gearbeitet ich
habe viel gelernt durch die
zusammenarbeit mit den israelis ich kann
ihre perspektive verstehen wir sind uns
oft mich ein ich aber ich kenne sie
persönlich ich habe mit ihnen gelebt und
ich kann auch einen teil ihrer sorgen
und auch ihre ängste verstehen
aber er sagte mir meine kinder die jetzt
aufgewachsen sind in gaza und die
überhaupt keinen israel mehr persönlich
kennen haben nie eingesehen kennen nur
noch die drohnen und die angriffe das
trägt natürlich langfristig zu keinen
zusammenleben bei und zu keiner
regionalen sicherheit und diese themen
glaube ich muss man und gerade da
braucht es leute die dann den dialog
weiterführen und nicht unbedingt beide
seiten noch weiter in ihren
überzeugungen befestigen
es gibt natürlich auch kaum mehr eine
familie in diesem gebiet die nicht
menschen verloren hat in der eigenen
familie innerhalb dieses sehr lange
dauern den nahostkonflikt jetzt bereits
aber trotzdem noch einmal auf eine frage
der umstand dass unrecht historisches
unrecht eigentlich der anfang war dieses
ganzen konflikt es macht es diesen
konflikt nicht eben die noch einmal
speziell gefährlich oder speziell
brisant ja natürlich gefährlich schon
mal dadurch dass eben wie sie diese
selber betont haben jede familie
betroffen wurde irgendwann mal in dieser
ganzen zeit und auch beim einsatz den
wir jetzt haben für die
palästinensischen flüchtlinge ich war
vor kurzem in syrien das sind natürlich
durch den jetzigen krieg schon wieder
zehntausende von palästinensischen
flüchtlingen die damals 48 oder 67er
palästina verlassen mussten
wer jetzt sind sie in syrien vertrieben
die nächste generation geht jetzt durch
diesen traum des des vertreiben science
und natürlich der gewalt und das sind so
sachen die sitzen sehr tief aber
natürlich muss die bevölkerung auch und
ich glaube gerade bei solchen personen
besteht natürlich auch dann die hoffnung
dass irgendwann mal etwas anderes kommt
und dass sie nicht ihr leben lang und
generationen lang durch diese sachen
weiterhin erleben müssen
19 49 wurde ja dann die unwra gegründet
das ist eben diese uno agentur der sie
jetzt vor stehen seit diesem frühling
was ist genau das mandat der ungar also
ursprünglich war das tatsächlich 700.000
personen wurden vertrieben mussten ihre
dörfer verlassen und dann plötzlich
aufgenommen worden
das waren damals im westjordanland egal
sein syrien im libanon und in jordanien
also heute und da wurde diese agentur
kreiert um unterstützung und auch
dienste zu leisten insbesondere im
bereich von erziehung und gesundheit
ursprünglich natürlich war die
vorstellung das wäre eine sehr kurze
erfahrung ein paar jahre bis leute in
ihre häuser zurückkehren könnten oder
eine lösung gefunden würde
für ihrer lage das ist nicht entstanden
es gibt keine politische lösung insofern
sind es jetzt inzwischen fünf millionen
palästinensische flüchtlinge in diesen
verschiedenen ländern und wir sind
weiterhin zuständig für diese
dienstleistung aber auch manchmal wie
jetzt in gaza oder in syrien für
noteinsätze natürlich wenn es besonders
kritisch wird
700.000 flüchtlinge 1948 heute fünf
millionen für die so sie sozusagen für
ihren schutz sie zuständig sind nicht
gerade eine geschichte des erfolgs nein
nicht in dem sinne dass der menschlichen
perspektive ganz bestimmt nicht und
natürlich das ist inzwischen die
bevölkerung laufwerken das muss man sich
mal vorstellen dass ohne und das sind
viele leute die weiterhin heute nicht
wissen ob irgendein mal irgendwann mal
eine lösung für sie gefunden welche
lösungen das ist es hätte natürlich viel
meiner meinung nach mit der kreation
eines staates palästina zu tun dann wäre
das natürlich für seine
zukunftsperspektiven die gibt es
momentan nicht deswegen sitzen sie
weiterhin in lagern in libanon in syrien
und sind ausgesetzt der besatzung und
der blockade natürlich zwischen
westjordanland und gaza und was genau
machen sie muss man sich das vorstellen
worin besteht ihre aufgabe also
persönlichen ist natürlich die
verantwortung allgemein für die
aktivitäten wir haben eben wie gesagt 5
millionen personen ist ungefähr drei
millionen die von unserer gesundheits
aktivitäten medizinische unterstützung
natürlich entgegen sie in verschiedenen
kliniken und das ist ein sehr wichtiger
beitrag regional auch zu einer gewissen
stabilität und erziehung ist sehr
wichtig erzählungen die schulen warum
man mit dem beispiel zu geben sind über
150 schulen in gaza die natürlich von
uns geführt werden und die klassen
werden von tausenden von lehrern und
arbeiten dort geführt das ist ein
wichtiger beitrag zur entwicklung dieser
ganzen bevölkerung aber es mangelt
weiterhin natürlich an der
zukunftsperspektive dass es eben eine
sorge für die sicherheit der gegend
herum sie haben vorhin gesagt 5
millionen flüchtlinge das entspricht der
bevölkerung von norwegen für otto
normalverbraucher für mich ist es noch
schwierig sich vorzustellen was ist
eigentlich die definition eines
flüchtlings in diesem kontext die haben
immer so dieses bild wie wir das hier
gesehen haben die palästinenser die
fliehenden hab und gut auf dem kopf auf
den schultern
das sind ja menschen die doch wieder
irgendwo ansässig sind wie definiert man
eigentlich flüchtlingen zum kontext
flüchtlinge sind in diesem fall wurden
definiert von der uno-vollversammlung
als die person die damals zwischen 1946
und 48 in palästina gelebt haben und
natürlich inzwischen sind es auch ihre
kinder und die folgenden generationen
das entspricht auch den definition des
hochkommissars für flüchtlinge und
während wir jetzt in afghanistan hätten
afghanische flüchtlinge in pakistan oder
iran ist das genauso wenn ein kind als
afghane in pakistan aufwächst dann ist
er weiterhin ein flüchtling natürlich
ein großer unterschied
der afghane kann nach afghanistan
zurückkehren wenn die bedingungen recht
sind so kann ein palästinenser nicht
nach palästina zurückkehren weil es kein
land gibt und insofern ist natürlich
dass gerade die abwesenheit man den
mangel an lösungen in der politik im
politischen sinn
die zentrale frage um diese situation zu
lösen
aber kann ein palästinenser
beispielsweise jederzeitigen den
gazastreifen zurück gehen ja aber es ist
natürlich kein staat und ich glaube hier
muss man sehen dass ist bieten die eine
zukunftsperspektive und momentan sind
als von den 1,7 millionen einwohnern im
gazastreifen 1,2 millionen registrierte
flüchtlinge
das ist also schon über 70 prozent der
bevölkerung in gaza ist heute schon bei
uns als flüchtlinge registriert
das kann man dass es als unhaltbar als
zukunftsperspektive besonders wo sie ja
auch gar keine arbeit mehr finden weil
die blockade es nicht ermöglicht mit
israel wie früher oder mit dem west
ihren langen zu handeln
es gibt also keine arbeitsperspektiven
für die leute dass es auch in dem sinne
nicht haltbar
schauen wir uns die situation an ich
habe hier eine karte gesehen hier den
gazastreifen
sie haben es bereits erwähnt das gebiet
des gazastreifens das ist ungefähr so
groß wie die stadt genf und da wohnen
1,7 millionen menschen
wie geht es diesen menschen jetzt nach
diesem dritten krieg innerhalb von sechs
jahren
also als ich im april zum ersten mal in
dieser neuen rolle den gazastreifen
besuchte wurde mir sofort klar dass es
eben menschlich unhaltbar ist wenn 40
prozent der bevölkerung arbeitslos ist
65 prozent der jugendlichen bevölkerung
und über 80 prozent der frauen wenn es
da keine perspektiven geht dass sich
leute investieren wenn 830.000 personen
damals vor dem konflikt schon abhängig
waren von unserer nahrungsmittel
unterstützung dann ist irgendwas völlig
falsch und wenn man jetzt noch da
hinzufügt dass der krieg und die ausmaß
der zerstörung 20.000 wohneinheiten
wurden jetzt in diesen krieg zerstört
das heißt wir haben zwischen 100 und 120
tausend personen die jetzt keine wohnung
kein haus mehr finden werden
und jetzt wo es bald auch zum winter
kommt in einer situation in einer
notlage in eine problematik die auch
rechte und würde gar nicht mehr
anerkennen überleben müssen und auch das
trägt langfristig zu
sicherheitsproblemen in der region sehr
wichtig und sehr problematisch bei ihr
hatten sie das persönlich ausführliche
menschen zuständig zu sein
also ich jetzt hier immer sehr viel
kraft und das seit jahren aus solchen
lagen weil ich immer meine wenn ich
meine probleme mit den problemen der
bevölkerung in gaza vergleicht dann sind
meine probleme wirklich sehr klein und
sehr bescheiden und ich finde immer dass
dieses menschliche sich einsetzen für
die würde und die anerkennung der
menschen ist sehr wichtig hab ich auch
gewährt dagegen dass man die
palästinenser jetzt während dieses
krieges auf statistiken reduziert das
kann ich wirklich damit kann ich mich
überhaupt nicht abfinden dass man sagt
das waren jetzt 1800 tote und 10.000
verletzte das heißt überhaupt nichts
aber wenn ich im spital in ski phase und
wie die kinder dort in den betten liegen
und mit den wunden die man in seinem
leben am liebsten nie sehen würden wenn
ich in die eltern in die augen schauen
dann weiß ich dass es im menschlichen
sinne so ein krieg einfach nicht mehr
geben darf und dass lösungen gefunden
werden müssen und dass jede hinter jeder
statistik und jeder zahl eine familie
ist wie ihre weine und die gleichen
hoffnung haben auf ein besseres leben
das büro der uno agentur für
palästina-flüchtlinge befindet sich in
ostjerusalem sie leben also nicht im
gazastreifen seien sie nicht aus der
rosalie und sie reißen auch sehr viel in
israel natürlich herum wie geht es denn
den israelischen bürgerinnen und bürgern
ich glaube den israelischen bürgern
bürger geht es in dieser phase auch
nicht gut weil sie hatten natürlich sie
waren den raketen schützen ausgesetzt
und es ist ich habe mit vielen
gesprochen wo man natürlich merkt dass
sie als familien als eltern sich die
sorgen machen wenn abends die diese
angriffe kommen und sie müssen schutz
finden und sie machen sich sorgen über
die sicherheit ihrer familien das ist
absolut klar
und das kann ich durchaus mit
einbeziehen und nachvollziehen was ich
dann natürlich auch schauen muss ist
ausmaß der zerstörung auf einer seite
und auf der anderen und das kann man
einfach jetzt rein indem sie eine
statistisch nicht vergleichen
die anzahl aber das leiden und die sorge
das kann ich durchaus mit einbeziehen
will ich gerade auch noch hinzufügen
ich habe mehrmals aus gaza direkt also
nicht aus der sicherheit meiner wohnung
in ost jerusalem oder aus meiner wohnung
in genf seine aus gaza für das
einstellen der raketenbeschüsse geredet
und ich habe mich eingesetzt und ich
habe auch verurteilt dass diese raketen
schüsse auf städte und menschen
gerichtet wurden
das ist auch teil der rolle die ich sehe
aber natürlich wenn es dann zu 500 toten
kindern kommt in gaza dann weiß ich dass
kann man einfach menschlich nicht
akzeptieren und auch das muss verurteilt
werden wenn sie so erzählen von diesen
verletzten kindern in diesen
krankenhäusern und wenn ihr auch die
bilder sehen hierzulande von den
zerstörten städten
dann fragt man sich ja mal schauen wer
um himmels willen hat eigentlich ein
interesse an diesen konflikt
ich glaube es ist sehr schwierig aus
konflikt logik heraus zu kommen
es gibt dann in jedem krieg das habe ich
auch in anderen kriegen gesehen gibt es
interessen
dass leute die interesse haben dass die
situation sich nicht löst das die lage
weiterhin sich zuspitzt weil sie
weiterhin natürlich in ihren eigenen
positionen sein können und und auch in
ihren positionen bestehen können und ich
glaube ich jetzt dass es gerade wo es
andere vermittlerrolle braucht es
braucht leute die nicht nur beide seiten
in ihren überzeugungen bekräftigen
sondern eben auch sagen es muss jetzt
irgendwann mal zu schwierigen
entscheidungen kommen und jeder muss
auch ein schritt in die richtung des
anderen machen können auch teil wieder
der perspektive des anderen
aber was man vielleicht nicht ganz gut
genug versteht ist dass es jetzt sich
nicht um zwei länder handelt die gegen
sich gegen einander gegenseitig krieg
führen das ist eine besatzung in den
palästinensischen gebieten mit blockade
in gaza und besatzung im westjordanland
und in gaza
und das führt natürlich langfristig zu
sehr viel spannung bewegungsfreiheit
gibt es nicht für palästinenser die
siedlung unter dem völkerrecht illegal
sind werden weiter gebaut und das sind
natürlich sachen die müssen irgendwann
mal politisch angepackt werden was
meinen sie mit besatzung besatzung
besetzten gebiete das heißt unter dem
völkerrecht wenn ein militär
interveniert in einem gebiet und eine
bevölkerung kontrolliert ist das unter
dem genfer konventionen besatzung und
das bringt natürlich verantwortung für
die besatzungsmacht mit sich
insbesondere die realität an ort und
stelle jetzt im westjordanland und gaza
nicht schwerwiegend für die bevölkerung
zu beenden
und jetzt ist das natürlich mit dem
siedlungen gerade ein sehr großes
problem
wobei israelischer zum teil schon so
darstellen würde dass sie nicht eine
besatzungsmacht sind sondern sie
wiederum sich verteidigen müssen weil
die dauernd von raketen von seiten der
hamas beschossen werden
ja und das ist natürlich teil der
polarisierung und der debatte in diesem
habe ich glaube es wird von der
internationalen gemeinschaft anerkannt
das ist eine besatzung gibt und das ist
unter dieser besatzung verantwortung für
israel gibt natürlich darf israel
maßnahmen ergreifen um sein
der bevölkerung zu schützen habe ich
komme wieder auf den punkt zurück
israel hat verantwortung unter dem
völkerrecht und das völkerrecht erlaubt
es einem nicht land zu gebrauchen
umsiedlung aufzubauen dass es anerkannt
international als eine verletzung des
völkerrechtes sie haben vorhin als
antwort auf meine frage wir haben nicht
ein interesse an diesem konflikt hat
gesagt dass er schwierig diese konflikt
spirale zu verlassen
in diesem zusammenhang kann man sich ja
mal die frage stellen warum schafft es
die zivilbevölkerung nicht wenn der
druck genug gross würde auf beiden
seiten dass sie zuviel bevölkerung sagt
es reicht dann könnte sich ja vielleicht
etwas bewegen und es gab ja 2011 ein
manifest von jungen palästinenserinnen
und palästinensern
das hat begonnen zwar im internet
publiziert mit den worten vor kameras
und dann geht es aber weiter
es besteht auch die vertrags beschimpft
die uno es beschimpft israel alle seiten
eigentlich und sie sagen wir haben
einfach genug wir wollen nicht mehr
dahin vegetieren in einem gebiet in dem
er eingesperrt sind wir wollen nicht
mehr von der hamas verprügelt werden und
wir wollen aber auch nicht mehr
ignoriert werden vom rest der welt warum
verpuffen solche aufrufe weil es immer
wieder krieg gibt natürlich wenn es
krieg gibt ist natürlich der kosten
einer anderen position wird wird sehr
hoch
eine eine position die irgendwie als
neue empfunden wird oder ein raum für
eine debatte wird geschlossen während
des krieges das hat man jetzt auch
wieder gesehen wenn es zu so extrem
angriffen kommt können so viel leid und
wenn so viele leute ums leben kommen und
verletzte gibt dann ist eigentlich der
raum für solche debatten nicht
geschaffen und es braucht diesen raum
ich bin durchaus dafür ich bin auch
selber dafür dass es eines tages keine
unruhe mehr braucht und dass die leute
in gaza also für mich ist es kein stolz
wenn wir 830.000 und jetzt nach dem
krieg 1,1 millionen personen abhängig
sind von unruh nahrungsmittel
unterstützen das also nicht meine
vorstellung eines guten lebens ich
möchte sehen dass leute in gaza
arbeitsplätze finden wieder weil die
blockade beendet wird und es ermöglicht
zu handeln mit israel wie
mit dem westjordanland mit europa und
dass leute ihre eigenen familien
unterstützen können das ist meine
vorstellung von würde und recht nicht
dass sie auf uns abhängig sind insofern
finde ich es auch wichtig dass neue
generation einen raum finden sich
ausdrücken zu können sich zu engagieren
aber sie müssen das schon sehen das ist
natürlich unter dem druck der besatzung
unter dem druck des unrechts unter dem
druck des konfliktes sehr schwierig ist
für personen den ordentlichen raum zu
finden für solche debatten und für
solche ideen 2006 hat ja eine mehrheit
der palästinenserinnen und palästinenser
hamas gewählt
das musste damals sehr kritisch
kommentiert im westen die hamas wurde
auch nicht akzeptiert dass
regierungspartei die eu und die usa
bezeichnen die hamas nach wie vor als
terror-organisation nur die schweiz und
norwegen sprechen mit der hamas finden
sie das richtig
also ich finde erstmals wenn man das
allgemein betrachtet wir haben es
natürlich oft gesehen dass wenn man
wahlen will aber dann das resultat nicht
als positiv sieht dann ist das natürlich
offen dilemma und das hat man jetzt auch
in gaza gesehen persönlich setze ich
mich immer für dialog ein muss ich sagen
weil ich habe jetzt 25 jahre in
kriegsgebieten gearbeitet ich habe es so
oft gehört wir werden nie mit dieser
gruppe oder mit jener gruppe diskutieren
diese sind so und und schlussendlich
wenn es dann zur lösung kommen muss
setzt man sich immer irgendwann mal mit
der anderen seite zusammen wir sehen uns
jetzt momentan in kolumbien in kolumbien
ist sind die fortschritte jetzt am
meisten dadurch erreicht worden dass man
sich endlich hingesetzt hat die
regierung sitzt mit der farc jahrelang
hat man gesagt man wird sich nie
hinsetzen
jetzt setzt man verhandelt man
irgendwann geschieht das ob das jetzt
akzeptabel ist im falle für gaza für die
internationale gemeinschaft das ist eine
andere frage da muss ich mich jetzt
nicht dazu äußern
das sieht der generalsekretär der uno
das muss er betrachten aber die tatsache
ist irgendwann muss es zu dialog kommen
insofern finde ich persönlich dass es
richtig ist wenn norwegen und die
schweiz sich einsetzen ich finde es
wichtig in jedem konfliktes kanäle offen
bleiben
versuchen zu können lösung herbei zu
bringen sie haben bereits erwähnt dass
sie schon über 20 jahre erfahrung haben
mit konflikten sie waren sehr lange beim
ikk in dieser ganzen zeit sie war zwölf
jahre auch operationeller direktor des
ikk sie waren in el salvador sie waren
in chile in bosnien in serbien in
afghanistan sie kennen ganz viele dieser
konflikte wirklich von innen gab es in
dieser ganzen zeit nie kriegsparteien
oder irgendwelche rebellengruppen bei
denen sie gesagt haben mit diesen rede
ich jetzt aber wirklich nicht gut in der
rolle war das in dem sinne keine frage
weil es einfach zum zur arbeit des ikk
gehört mit allen kriegsparteien dialog
zu führen dann gibt es immer
kriegsparteien die wollen keinen dialog
führen das ist eine andere frage aber in
einer ihk haben da habe ich mit den
verschiedensten gruppen mit dem
leuchtenden pfad im büro mit lte in sri
lanka damit den taliban in afghanistan
und das habe ich dialog geführt und wir
haben und warum hört man in dem fall
dialog nicht weil es interessant ist
eine lange liste nennen zu können nach
20 jahren mit dem man dialog geführt hat
sondern weil es ein einsatz ist um die
bevölkerung in konkreten situationen
schützen zu können
wenn angriffe auf zivilbevölkerung
passieren da muss man sich hinsetzen mit
den führern dieser gruppen und das
diskutieren dass damit sich das ende hat
einen einfluss auszuüben
an ort und stelle das habe ich natürlich
auch mit staaten gemacht das habe ich
nach abu ghraib mit den amerikanern
gemacht ist mache ich jetzt mit israel
ist sehr wichtig diesen dialog zu führen
also für mich ist das ein bestandteil
meiner art und weise in solchen
situationen aufzutreten
es ist natürlich ein großes dilemma
persönlich ich habe natürlich mit leuten
gesessen mit denen man eigentlich nicht
sitzen möchte kann man sich gar nicht
gerne angenommen man führt mich gerne
dialog mit jemand von dem man weiß der
hat jetzt jemand in seinem gefängnis
gefoltert hat einen dorf angegriffen und
da wurden frauen vergewaltigt und kinder
getötet aber das gehört zum zur rolle
des ik cars und ich sehe es jetzt auch
in der uno als bestandteil meiner rolle
mit allen versuchen im dialog zu führen
in dem sinne ist es für mich sehr
wichtig mit der palästinensischen
behörde und auch mit israel regelmäßig
im kontakt
zu stellen sie sind vater von drei
kindern gibt es nie eine situation muss
ich richtig angst hatten
also ich habe oft in meinen 25 jahren
angst gehabt weil wenn man den
kriegsgebieten arbeitet dann dann hat
man angst und ich finde das ist auch ein
schutz für sich selber es geht hier
nicht um heldentaten
ich habe das nie gemacht findet es auch
nicht angebracht dass man denkt man
kommt aus dem ausland und denkt man sei
irgendwie ein held wenn man sieht was
die leute dort ausgesetzt sind also die
helden die wahren helden das sind die
ärzte in gaza die ihre eigenen
bevölkerung unterstützen das sind meine
palästinensischen kollegen das war
damals meine afghanischen kollegen meine
bosnischen kollegen das sind helden die
sich einsetzen ihren in ihrem eigenen
land aber ich sehe als natürlich die
verantwortung die ich habe ist diese
bevölkerung während einigen jahren zu
begleiten und in diesen wirklich sehr
schwierigen momenten zu unterstützen
das sehe ich als meine rolle aber angst
gehört auch dazu weil wir noch einmal
zurückgehen zum gaza konflikt sprechen
sie selber denn auch mit hamas
vertretern
also es gibt kontakte für operationelle
gründe und für sicherheitsgründe sind so
technische kontakte die existieren
zwischen rohr und und hamas die sind
auch notwendig weil es ganz einfach ein
akteur ist er dort für sicherheit oder
teilweise unsicherheit natürlich sehr
präsent sind und wir müssen diesen
technischen dialog dort führen dass der
sex gehört ist und es gibt es die hamas
hat ja in ihren statuten geschrieben
dass sie den staat israel hat nicht
nicht akzeptiert respektive sie möchten
gerne einen palästinensischen staat der
auch das gebiet das territorium des
heutigen israels einnehmen würde
nun hat man aber immer wieder auch
andere dinge gehört von der hammer sie
haben sich zum teil dann auch wieder
gemäßigter geäußert das war auch schon
die rede davon dass auch vertreter der
hamas eine zwei staaten lösung
unterstützen würden was denken sie
persönlich wo steht die hammers heute
also ich kann mich schlecht dazu äußern
weil ich bin in meiner rolle ist es
keine politische rolle
also ich kann jetzt nicht standpunkt der
hamas vertreten ich lerne was wichtig
ist ist wir wissen
israel existiert hat ein recht darauf
dass es anerkannt durch die uno
vollversammlung seit jahrzehnten und das
wird sich nicht ändern
das ist ein recht für israel und das
muss auch von allen akzeptiert werden
andererseits ist es stimmt es natürlich
dass die tatsache dass es noch nicht zu
einer zwei staaten lösung gekommen ist
ist natürlich kein beitrag zur
regionalen stabilität und so würde der
palästinenser
und das muss auch irgendwann mal
anerkannt werden sonst gibt es weiterhin
spannung aber zur spezifischen
standpunkte der hamas dazu kann ich mich
momentan nicht äußern
jetzt hat die waffenruhe wurde ja
logischerweise an bedingungen geknüpft
und eine der bedingungen der hamas war
dass diese blockade gelockert wird
inwiefern ist israel hamas
entgegengekommen hat sich etwas bewegt
also momentan hat sich dort nichts
bewegt ist die diskussion werden jetzt
noch weitergeführt oder sollen jetzt
noch weitergeführt werden aber wenn ich
das jetzt mal trennen kann vom
politischen weil das wird oft politisch
betrachtet mit der blockade
ich werde das jetzt einfach mal
menschlich beschreiben
ich traf im juni einen familienvater der
war jahrelang hat er sein eigenes
unternehmen hat 50 personen angestellt
war im austausch und handel mit israel
hat seine produkte verkauften
westjordanland und hatte dort war
wirklich auch sehr erfolgreich den traf
ich weil er hatte inzwischen als
resultat der blockade und das ist ganz
klar
als resultat der blockade weil er nichts
mehr exportieren kann sein unternehmen
verloren musste die 50 personen
entlassen hat sein haus verloren weil er
so viele schulden hatte und stand vor
seinen kindern und hat mir erklärt wie
es jetzt aussieht da er jetzt von der
unruhe nahrungsmittel erhält das ist
nicht was die zukunft sein muss für ihn
und soll er will zurück zur arbeit er
will seine familie selbst unterstützen
das ist jetzt eine zentrale frage der
würde das hat mit den standpunkten
politisch nichts mehr zu tun das ist
eine menschliche frage und notwendigkeit
und da muss die blockade jetzt nicht nur
ein bisschen geändert werden sie muss
aufgehoben werden aber da fragt man sich
doch noch einmal warum kommt denn zu
etwas wer hat ein interesse an dieser
blockade
die die menschen der massen april liegt
ihm gar verstreichen ja gut das ist das
müssen sie die fragen die zuständig sind
das ist natürlich jetzt eine
entscheidung in israel hat diese
blockade aufgebaut sie hat das ist
sicher als auf sicherheits perspektiven
gesehen meine perspektive ist nicht die
sicherheits perspektive ich kann sie mit
einbeziehen
das ist nicht meine meine ist die
menschliche perspektive und wenn ich
sehe dass 1,8 millionen personen keine
zukunftsperspektiven haben und sich
sorgen machen müssen dass sie jetzt
morgen noch mal von der unruhe
nahrungsmittel unterstützung erhalten
und keine arbeit haben um selber die
familie zu unterstützen
dann sehe ich das als ein großes risiko
für die ganze gegend in der zukunft aber
sicherheit kann man ja nicht einfach
abkoppeln von menschlichen bedürfnissen
oder belangen und das war ja auch
sozusagen die bedingung von seiten
israels dass sie gesagt haben wir wollen
aber auch dass unsere sicherheit
gewährleistet wird wie wollen wir nicht
mehr beschlossen werden
und was hat ja auch sehr viel zu tun mit
menschlichen videos nicht aber da muss
man natürlich irgendwann mal analysieren
ob diese strategie wenn das überhaupt
diese strategie ist und dazu kann ich
mich jetzt nicht äußern das ist nicht
meine rolle
ich bin kein das box man für die
israelische perspektive bin ich auch
nicht für die hammers perspektive das
ist nicht meine rolle aber wenn das
jetzt tatsächlich der fall ist da muss
man natürlich nach drei kriegen in gaza
irgendwann mal analysieren ob das zu
mehr sicherheit führt und ich glaube
meine das wenn leute arbeitsplätze
finden wenn sie die würde anerkannt wird
wenn sie selber zuständig sind für die
situation ihrer familie wenn sie wieder
bewegungsfreiheit haben wenn die
bevölkerung in gaza wieder hoffnung
kriegt dass es ein anderes leben möglich
ist dann trägt das meiner meinung nach
zu mehr sicherheit
kurz mittel und langfristig bei als
jedes zweite jahr einen krieg zu führen
und junge leute wachsen im gazastreifen
und in israel auf ohne sich zu kennen
das finde ich mache mir genau so viel
sorgen wie was wir jetzt beobachten
sprechen wir über ihr mandat sie sind
jetzt der raum höchste schweizer bei der
uno und die uno ist das haben sie selber
vorhin auch schon gesagt die vereinten
nationen die anerkennen palästina nicht
als staat sondern palästina hat nur
einen beobachterstatus können sie
dennoch hinter der uno stehen ja ich
finde das ist natürlich ein für mich
sehr wichtiger als jetzt bei der unrwa
erstmal weil dieses mandat 1949 da muss
man sich vorstellen da war die uno
selbst erst 34 jahre alt dass das ist
dieses mandat entstanden und war gerade
weil es diese lösung noch nicht gegeben
hat politisch natürlich da spielt auch
die und eine rolle da spielen sie spielt
die staatengemeinschaft eine rolle in
der diesen scheitern das ist keine
lösung gegeben hat finde ich von der
menschlichen perspektive diesen einsatz
sehr wichtig dass diese bevölkerung
nicht nur in diesen lagern sitzt sondern
wir ziehung bekommt zukunftsperspektiven
bekommt und sie müssen sich das mal
vorstellen wenn es morgen zu einem
palästinensischen staat käme dann hat
die uno a 65 jahre lang ein riesen
beitrag geleistet gerade durch die
erziehung gerade durch die schulen weil
leute vorbereitet sind rollen zu
übernehmen in einen zukünftigen staates
das war auch nach dem oslo abkommen die
idee da wäre dabei sein über eine fünf
jahre periode einen übergangsprozess
dann hätte das unrwa personal wäre an
die palästinensische behörde überwinden
und dann hätte der neue staat auch diese
kräfte mit einbezogen das ist ein
wichtiger beitrag
und das wäre ja auch sehr schön gewesen
es hätte geglaubt tatsächlich ist er
dann aus konflikt ein beispiel dafür
dass die diplomatie nicht so erfolgreich
war also es gab diese oslo auf
friedensverhandlungen man denke auch an
die camp david verhandlungen hat immer
wieder diplomatisch darum gerungen eine
lösung zu finden
denken sie die diplomatie ist an diesem
ort schlicht einfach zu ende
nein zu ende ist sie nicht und sie ist
notwendiger je weil es einfach man kann
es nicht akzeptieren man kann es auch
nicht passieren lassen dass es wahr dass
diese polarisierung
weiter besteht das muss es halt auch
sexuell carey hat das versucht neun
monate lang letzten letztes jahr und am
anfang dieses jahres solche versuche
muss es weiterhin geben ich finde mich
besorgt wenn ich so meine ikk erfahrung
und jetzt diese erfahrung mit unserer
betrachte ich sehe wie nach dem 11
september 2001 seitdem ist er wirklich
die versuchung in der internationalen
gemeinschaft meiner ansicht nach sehr
groß erst einmal militärisch zu denken
es gibt eine krise irgendwo man muss
sich militärisch einsetzen und dann
frage ich immer in welchem konflikt
haben wir jetzt in den letzten jahren
gesehen dass ein militärischer einsatz
zu mehr stabilität geführt hat im irak
in afghanistan und libyen und da muss
man daraus auch manchmal den schluss
ziehen dass die versuchung groß sein
kann entweder diesen militärischen
einsatz zu betrachten oder den
humanitären einsatz möglicherweise weil
leute einfach die geduld für die politik
und die vermittlung nicht mehr haben wir
leben in einer zeit wo man am montag
eine krise betrachten will am freitag
soll sie beendet sein und dann muss man
dann hat man das wochenende um andere
sachen zu machen
so geht das nicht es braucht jahrelang
engagement und eine kultur der
vermittlung eine legitimierung der
vermittlung ist in der heutigen welt
sehr sehr wichtig und leider gibt es das
moment nicht es gab ja tatsächlich so
eine ära des sogenannten
interventionismus angefangen mit der
sogenannten humanitären intervention im
kosovo damals und dann verschiedene
beispiele aber viele haben auch gesagt
es war eigentlich diese idee des
interventionismus sich die idee dass man
mit einer militärischen intervention
konflikt in anderen staaten lösen kann
ist eigentlich gescheitert zu ende
gegangen mit dem dritten irak krieg also
tatsächlich man hat auf dieser schiene
jetzt weiter gedacht das ist nicht so
dass man im moment wieder eher davon ab
kommt ich hatte für dieses konzept dass
meine deren einsatz der humanitären
intervention nie viel geduld also ich
muss sagen das war eine art
krieg mit humanitärem der worten
vermischen und das hat nie zu guten
lösungen geführt meiner ansicht nach und
vermeidet das heute ja glaub ich auch er
und spricht wieder von militärischen
internet genauso mann soll dann sachen
nennen wie sie sind wenn man zu einem
einsatz kommt oder man meinte er sei
notwendig das ist wie gesagt das ist
vielleicht nicht meine ansicht aber ist
dann da muss man das so nennen man führt
dann kriegt man führt nicht was an dass
man führt krieg meiner ansicht nach ist
aber jetzt sehr wichtig dass man wie der
politik führt und dass diplomatie den
raum hat weil in den heutigen kriegen
das sind alles langfristige kriege
schauen sie doch mal kolumbien 50 jahre
krieg afghanistan 35 jahre krieg kongo
35 jahre krieg das braucht politischen
einsatz politisches management und daran
mangelt ist momentan und es ist
eigentlich gibt auch ein grund warum
weil das internationale system nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg aufgebaut wurde
in einer zeit wo die meisten kriege
zwischen staaten geführt wurden und da
war natürlich die uno der logische
partner und vermittler weil es eben eine
staaten struktur und eine organisation
ist starten die mitglieder sind
heutzutage sind die meisten konflikte in
der welt zwischen staaten und nicht
staatlichen strukturen und da sind
natürlich starken besonders empfindlich
wenn die uno oder wenn andere vermittler
sich engagieren zwischen ihnen und ihrer
internen opposition aber die situation
ist es braucht jemand und es braucht
akteure ich glaube wirklich dass die
schweiz da eine rolle spielen kann
gerade weil dann die neutralität einen
sinn hat weil man sich engagiert wo
andere sich nicht engagieren können aus
politischen gründen aus
empfindlichkeiten
es braucht diese kanäle und dafür nicht
sehr überzeugt
in diesen neuen kriegen in denen sich
eben nicht mehr staaten gegenüber einem
stehen da könnte man ja auch sagen ist
eigentlich das bedürfnis sehr groß nach
einer anpassung des völkerrechts weil
eben das völkerrecht auch staaten als
einzige akteure eigentlich akzeptiert ja
gut als aber ein großer unterschied und
eine große ausnahme im völkerrecht das
ist dass humanitäre vergleicht und das
humanitäre völkerrecht hat und das von
anfang an auch verantwortung mit sich
gebracht für nicht staatliche akteure
also wenn ich damals annika und in
meinen früheren kollegen beim ikk heute
im einsatz stehen afghanistan
dann kann man das völker humanitär
erfolgreich gebrauchen als grundlage für
einen dialog nicht nur mit den
amerikanischen streitkräften in
afghanistan oder mit den afghanischen
streitkräften sondern auch mit den
taliban weil sie auch verantwortung
haben und sanitären vergleich und ich
glaube man muss sehr vorsichtig mit der
idee gehen dass man existierendes recht
ändert man kann anderes hinzufügen
in dem sinne der anpassung weil neue
realitäten sich entwickeln aber sowohl
das humanitäre völkerrecht mit den
genfer konventionen sowie menschenrechte
sind natürlich auch resultate der
katastrophalen lage nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg
da müssen wir sehr aufpassen dass
natürlich was wir als erbe aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg mit uns tragen heute
nicht in dem sinne ändern und denken
im zweiten weltkrieg waren sie nicht
kreativ genug was jetzt die fähigkeit
des menschen einem anderen menschen leid
anzutun ich meine da hat es wirklich an
nichts gemangelt und das resultat war
menschenrechte humanitäres völkerrecht
zu stärken
das müssen wir heute sehr schützen aber
es gibt neue realität und die muss man
auch mit einbeziehen das ist richtig sie
plädieren sehr stark für eine art neue
diplomatie in der wir eben mit diesen
verschiedenen auch nichtstaatlichen
gruppierungen sprechen im moment blickt
die ganze welt schockiert auf die es
terror milizen auf die dinge die da
geschehen entführungen von journalisten
enthauptungen dialog zu suchen mit
solchen milizen scheint glaube ich für
sie für sehr viele menschen schlicht
respektiv auch einfach viel zu
gefährlich glauben sie wirklich da kommt
man weiter mit diplomatischen ideen also
es gibt momente wo man sich ja an eine
grenze kommt erst mal emotional
natürlich nochmal das sieht man mit den
enthauptungen und den den angegriffenen
die jetzt stattfinden teilen syriens und
irak ist man erstmal zutiefst schockiert
erschüttert und man macht sich einfach
auch von gerechtfertigt sorgen für nicht
nur die regionale stabilität dem
mittleren osten unseren im weiteren
sinne
aber ich stelle einfach noch mal die
frage und ich finde in dem wenig
verstehe ich durchaus dass man sagt man
kann jetzt sich nicht vorstellen dass es
unbedingt jetzt ein dialog gibt dass
leute die so rauch darauf reagieren
müssen das verstehe ich nur meine sorge
ist ich will nicht in diesem konflikt
recht haben
das ist nicht meine perspektive ich will
in einen einfluss haben und eine lage
beeinflussen das hat mit mir persönlich
nichts zu tun hat mit der
internationalen gemeinschaft ich suche
dass man eine verbesserung der lage für
die bevölkerung im irak in afghanistan
in anderen ländern
herr beibringen kann und meine frage ist
hat die art und weise wie seit dem 11
september 2001 diese militärischen
einsätze jetzt geführt wurden zu mehr
stabilität beigetragen und meine antwort
ist nein
und insofern denke ich ist es
gerechtfertigt dass man sich auch andere
perspektiven anschaut und dass man auch
politisch und diplomatisch denkt das
heißt nicht dass es nicht irgendwann zu
einem militärischen einsatz gegen eine
gruppe kommen kann
aber ich finde wenn man das analysiert
muss man auch die resultate an ort und
stelle objektiv analysiert also
militärische intervention bringen's
nicht diplomatie sagen sie wäre der
königsweg gibt es da positive beispiel
bildung sie sagen da sehen wir doch dass
genug ausdauernd gibt diplomatie
wirklich zum erfolg geführt hat
ja gut das hat man bei versöhnung nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg ganz bestimmt
gesehen die gab es die polarisierung
zwischen deutschland und frankreich und
das vergisst man besonders in der
schweiz natürlich wie sehr die eu
natürlich einen sicherheitspakt
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg und zu der
längsten phase der sicherheit in europa
wir haben ein europa nie so eine lange
zeit der sicherheit gebracht das kam
nicht durch krieg das kam nachher durch
dialog diplomatie zusammenarbeit und das
hat uns die längste periode der
stabilität auf diesem kontinent gebracht
das muss man auch mal und betrachten
können deswegen glaube ich
zusammenarbeit auch bei parteien die
jetzt momentan sehr festgefahren sind
und ich denke an staaten
ich denke jetzt nicht unbedingt an wo
man im moment natürlich sehr schwierig
perspektiven sieht das irgendwie zu
einem dialog kommt sie sind nicht so aus
dass jemand dialog will und das
überhaupt möglich wäre sie haben es auch
recht zurecht erwähnt sicherheitsfragen
würden dass er wahrscheinlich überhaupt
gar nicht konkret ermöglichen aber eine
regionale zusammenarbeit dass gewisse
krisen ein ende finden und das bringt
uns natürlich auch auf palästina zurück
kann man sich wirklich erlauben
gleichzeitig die krise im irak und
syrien
die krisen in yemen die krisen und diese
langfristigen konflikte und und und die
abwesenheit der lösungen im krieg
zwischen palästinensern und israelis
noch lange mit sich zu tragen
da sage ich es lohnt sich jetzt das
politisch anzupacken
wir haben hier eine eine karte der der
gesamten region
wenn man die gesamte region im blick
nimmt hat man da wirklich das gefühl ist
eigentlich das ganze gebiet ein bisschen
aus den fugen
sehen sie wenn sie zehn jahre nach vorne
blicken haben sie hoffnung für dieses
gebiet also ich kann schon mal zwölf
jahre zurückblicken
als ich als direktor für operationelle
einsätze im juli 2002 beim ikk begann
dann hatten wir es mit irak unter den
sanktionen zu tun
damals noch mit saddam hussein und schon
natürlich palästina und israel und die
reste region war nicht unbedingt ideal
aber ist es war stabilität da heute kann
man wirklich diese karte betrachten mit
mit sehr vielen sorgen
und da gerade weil auch diplomatie und
politik langfristige aktionen sind
gibt es keine kurzfristigen lösungen
geben aber deswegen muss man ja jetzt
gerade beginnen weil sonst sind wir in
zehn jahren möglicherweise noch mit
einem schlechteren umfeld da und das
sollte auch mal aus einer europäischen
perspektive durchaus als
besorgniserregend betrachtet werden aber
das eigene interesse heraus sollten wir
uns jetzt mehr diplomatische diese
kombination zwischen eigeninteressen
natürlich sorgen für die leute im
mittleren osten selber und nicht so sehr
aus persönlichen oder politischen
überzeugungen recht haben zu wollen und
dann sagen die eine seite hat recht und
die andere hat nicht recht sondern dass
man sich engagiert und versuchen diese
seiten zusammenzubringen und den dialog
zu führen das ist für mich ein wirklich
ein zentraler punkt
sie haben die rolle der schweiz die
neutralität der schweiz und die
möglichkeit dank dieser neutralität
möglicherweise mit bestimmten
gruppierungen besonders gut sprechen zu
können dieses diesen dialog vielleicht
auch nicht führerschaft in diesem dialog
übernehmen zu können
in diesem zusammenhang die schweiz hat
sich ja auch immer wieder auf die fahne
geschrieben eine art friedensstifterin
zu sein
denken sie die schweiz wird heute diesen
ruf gerecht also ich glaube das ist viel
zeit gehabt während des kalten krieges
wo es auch wieder sehr anerkannt waren
erträgen und gorbatschow kam nach gerd
vogler war dort und so hat diese rolle
gespielt denn falls diese basis und
grundlage und stadt die natürlich alle
parteien irgendwann mal empfangen hat
und ich fand das war eine klare rolle
dann natürlich nach dem kalten krieg wo
es eben diese zwei blocks dann nicht
mehr gab dann war eine zeit der suche
nach einer identität was heißt die
neutralität jetzt nicht die schweizer
neutralität zu hause sondern im einsatz
international und wir wissen es gibt
auch in der schweiz viele debatten soll
man sich engagieren soll man sich nicht
engagieren ich finde einfach dass eine
neutralität insofern interessant ist nur
wenn sie ein aktives engagement
befürwortet deswegen finde ich es ist
wichtig dass die schweiz damals
natürlich dem uno beitritt zugesagt hat
2002 das ist eine form der solidarität
und das engagement sehr wichtig ist ein
land
dass so viel erreicht hat wie die
schweiz soll sich auch zur verfügung
stellen in krisengebieten das ist
natürlich ein risiko wenn man kann auch
etwas falsch machen
aber ich glaube ohne risiko wäre die
schweiz ja nie geworden was sie ist und
diese unternehmungslustig kite im
wirtschaftlichen bereich die darf man
auch in der politik engagieren
man muss neutral handeln in dem sinne
man muss nicht eine seite befürworten
und unterstützen über die andere aber
als land zur verfügung stehen finde ich
ist ein teil der schweizer identität mit
der ich mich also sehr tief
identifizieren sie plädieren für eine
aktive neutralität wird denn die
schweizer jetzt dieser aktiven
neutralität gerecht ich glaube man kann
noch mehr damit machen ich glaube gerade
dass sie gewisse versuche die jetzt
stattfinden natürlich gerade in diesem
jahr wo es auch mit der osze in der
ukraine natürlich und um den anderen
gebieten ich finde diese diese versuche
kanäle offen zu halten und nicht sofort
mit hier sanktionen da sanktionen
sondern erst mal sagen ich stehe zur
verfügung und die schweizer diplomatie
und der auch in der osze steht zur
verfügung obwohl ich das jetzt nicht
alltäglich verfolgen weil ich im moment
mit gasen mit syrien zu viel zu tun habe
aber das sehe ich als sehr wichtig und
das könnte sicher noch weiter entwickelt
werden ich finde das lohnt sich wirklich
und das ist ein schweizer neben teil der
schweizer identität
sie sind ein ort wo card der flüchtlinge
könnte man sagen wenn wir jetzt noch
einmal ums überlegen die die schweiz
eigentlich da steht wenn wir an libanon
denken ein lanz hat ein ganz das
ungefähr die hälfte der einwohner der
schweiz hat hat eine million flüchtlinge
viele viele syrer und viele
palästinenser aufgenommen in der schweiz
diskutiert man über kontingente von 500
personen reinlassen ja oder nein
sind sie da immer noch zufrieden mit der
schweiz damit habe ich mich schon
natürlich manchmal schwer also ich finde
gerade dieses beispiel das habe ich oft
selber gebraucht mit libanon dass er so
unter druck ist momentan
und wo natürlich die palästinensischen
flüchtlinge unter sehr großem druck
stehen historisch also sie können dort
nicht arbeiten
sie sitzen in den lagern aber dürfen
nicht arbeiten in den libanon das muss
man sich mal vorstellen
aber natürlich muss ich durchaus
anerkennen das was jetzt lieber namen
trägt eine riesige last ist das heißt
schweiz hat jetzt zwei millionen
deutsche 2 millionen franzosen zwei
millionen österreicher italiener
aufgenommen und wir müssen uns das mal
vorstellen was das überhaupt hier heißen
würde und das bringt sie auf ihren
kommentar da finde ich die debatten die
manchmal hier im land stattfinden über
400 500 und 4 friedemann aufnehmen kann
man geht einfach davon aus dass ja dass
die pakistan dass pakistan und iran das
mit den afghanen verkraften können dass
libanon und jordanien das mit den syrien
verkraften sollen aber wir sind etwas
anderes ich finde dass das gehört nicht
dazu dass also auf jeden fall muss man
dann sich energisch engagieren um
libanon zu unterstützen und auch die
lage der der syrischen flüchtlingen der
palästinensischen flüchtlinge zu
verbessern
sie reisen morgen zurück nach ost
jerusalem mit welchem gefühl gehen sie
heim immer mit dem gefühl dieses
engagement weiterzuführen ich bin sehr
mobilisiert auch sehr motiviert weil es
diese menschliche dimension einfach für
mich jetzt seit jahren gibt es gibt in
diesem posten kein filter ich bin nicht
in einem hauptsitz irgendwo in genf oder
new york sondern unruhe hat seinen
hauptsitz in dem kontext in der gegend
selber da ist bin ich also täglich
konfrontiert mit dem leiden mit dieser
suche nach würde und anerkennung der
palästinensischen flüchtlinge und das
ist ein engagement das sich als sehr
wichtig empfinden und das ich gerne
weiterführen glauben sie die der frieden
der jetzt geschlossen wurde für moment
lang die waffen darüber wird das haute
es ich glaube die zeichen sind das ist
halten wird aber es kommt natürlich dann
auch sehr darauf an was jetzt erreicht
wird in den weiteren diskussionen und
verhandlungen
und ich glaube es besteht ganz besonders
ein druck auf beide seiten auf alle
seiten dass es jetzt nicht einfach zu
einer situation kommt wo man zurückgeht
zu den vorher existierenden bedingungen
unter der blockade weil die blockade
habe ich vorhin beschrieben was das
menschlich mit sich bringt und wenn man
jetzt noch den ausmaß der zerstörung
hinzufügten was die bevölkerung jetzt
absolut unter schock noch steht ich habe
selber
die zehn von den zwölf familien von
unserer kollegen getroffen
die ums leben kam während dieses krieges
als zwölf kollegen haben wir verloren in
den letzten sieben wochen
das ist also jeder erzählt von sachen
die man am liebsten nicht wir wissen
möchte die die zwei brüder von einer
unserer kollegen die ums leben kam
die haben in einem angriff fünf brüder
und schwestern und fünf zusätzlich
kinder in einem angriff verloren das
muss die gesellschaft jetzt erstmal
verkraften
deswegen wollen wir als unruhe auch die
schulen so bald wie möglich öffnen wir
hoffen am 14 september dass die kinder
in die klassen zurück können es braucht
hoffnung es braucht er irgendwas das
auch an normalität erinnert aber wenn es
nur zurück zur blockade geht dann muss
ich wirklich auch sagen ist das risiko
natürlich sehr hoch dass es irgendwann
mal wie es jetzt schon in den letzten
jahren wieder zu krieg kommt und ich
glaube da kann niemand sagen das hätten
wir nicht erwartet
ja kein will ich danke ihnen sehr für
dieses gespräch
danke dass sie zu uns gekommen sind und
auch ihnen danke ich für ist interesse
danke fürs zuschauen in einer woche
erwartet sie hier meine kollegin katja
gentinetta mit einer debatte über
nationalismus und populismus in der
schweiz
wir freuen uns wenn sie wieder zu
schalten
[Musik]